it is a movie that seems to be on the
power track commercial circuit during
NFL and college football games and it
looks great it is great Michael Keaton
Taylor Kitsch Sanaa Lathan and my next
guest in American assassin Dylan O'Brien
in a theater near you Friday September
15th coming up later this week good to
see you sir you too rich nice to meet
you you bet now where do we start here
you want the real football with fantasy
football where do we start here
fantasies kind of dominate I'm a Jets
fan so fantasy let's go fantasy primary
that's fantasy why did last night's game
hurt you
you said you the Monday night game what
hurt you yeah I was I was gonna close I
was in a tight race week one and then
but I thought that I could pull it out
because I had Ingram and Thomas going
last night in the Monday night game oh
no my other guys only player left to go
was cook and left that'll wrap it up
yeah exactly I did it that's no good
yeah I don't know what is going on with
the Saints offense III I was I know the
Vikings have a pretty good defense
yeah it just looked just really good
last night though certainly when you
needed that yeah well is it they were
all so yeah just feels like when they're
on the road that's right why are you a
Jets fan uh I was born into it you know
I mean it's it's not you know totally
not my choice I love them okay but so
yeah my family's all like so York Long
Island Long Island yeah Long Island Long
Island okay so who's your favorite jet
growing up then growing up I mean I was
like a Wayne Chrebet kid you know but
yeah it's it's been a rough go of it you
know my dad never briefed me on when I
was a kid you know he never gave me the
brief you know what my life would become
now that's on your dad I'll be honest
with a little bit yeah but he's fine
it's gotta be on your dad yeah he
wouldn't had it any other way he
wouldn't have me going for the Giants
you know sir oh really yes to me cuz to
me the jet giant thing isn't nearly as
bad as the Yankee met thing used to be
yeah I know it's true it's true UK yeah
yeah with baseball you gotta be one of
these so you're met absolutely a diode
man oh my gosh yeah so where do you get
your championships from just the way you
know it's like an American assassin
where
with michael keaton who's a die-hard
Steeler fan is right yeah so I'm just
wondering the Jets and Steelers didn't
play each other while you were shooting
this sort of thing that was a couple of
years ago yeah that sort of thing
happened and you were in Deepwater
Horizon
I was yeah at with Pete Berg who's
diehard Giants yeah and Wahlberg who
would play for the Patriots have given
it yeah absolutely
did you have any conversations with him
jet Patriots no we never talked football
either really we're shooting the summer
I guess so it wasn't never hand of mine
yeah never came to mine idea I remember
that Pete was always making fun because
anytime we went we went to a bar one
time I remember and my Mets were beaten
no-hit by the Giants
I came in with a pitcher who was no
hitting them but uh it was it was I was
you know it's a game that doesn't matter
and yeah I'm in the bar just only you
know eyes glued to the TV just hoping
that my team doesn't get no hit right
and he just made fun of me I can't
remember I think they did you know it's
been a rough go of it for so are you oh
are you oh are you a Knick fan or
anything like that not really I'm not
huge into basketball local team wise I'm
not tired about a team but yeah I'll
root for the Knicks or nets always have
growing up but I usually just watch
basketballs become a whole whole
different thing okay Dylan O'Brien here
on the Rich Eisen show um now Chris
Brock went over there went to Syracuse
you almost went to Syracuse yeah we know
everything you do the dirt we dig we dig
deep oh no what are you digging to let
me let me know if there's any problems
but you almost went to search yeah I did
yeah I was deciding what to do about
school you know it's that classic you're
17 and you're kind of applying to
college is just trying to figure it out
I had no idea what I wanted to do you
know there are things I was interested
in I played music all throughout high
school I thought maybe I wanted to do
that I'm you know I'm obsessed with
baseball so I always had little dreams
of being if I couldn't play you know a
GM for the Mets obviously that you know
the dream wouldn't have been to be the
GM for the Mets or like a Gary Cohen or
something on announcer yeah it would
have been cool well I I could never why
never do it so is that why you were
gonna ever thinking going to Syracuse
because of the communications yeah well
yeah exactly
yeah yeah and that was it was just one
of the schools that got into you know
and I was thinking about it cuz I felt
like that was a path I totally go down
so before you had gotten acting you
thought sports broadcasting yeah I was
thinking about it yeah I think you're in
the right spot I know
look we're now exposing exactly why I
didn't go down that Reza we could have
you do a sideline report if you want to
see how you could I got some confidence
after last night something I feel for
that kid me too
big-time thank you not where you just
sit do you ever have a moment like that
on live stage or anything yeah I don't
know that's pretty unprecedented how
about like how about when your your
you're shooting a scene and you know
everybody's looking at you yeah and I
mean Michael Keaton is as good as they
come yeah yeah you've been in some of
these anything and well he you know with
Keaton I mean it helps you know you're
in a scene with a guy who's completely
engaged you know a guy who even just
because I grew up watching him you know
maybe for some reason like that you're
just totally more you just by him you
know in the scene with you and right and
he's just great and really fun to work
with and he's really good you know so
but yeah it is funny when you're doing
you know filmmaking is it's a it's a
funny thing you know you people don't
realize how long you kind of shoot a
scene for how many times you do it you
know right you know and for any and
you're trying to disappear into this
like little space and but you know you
got everybody we're talking about the
boom before you know things like that
that you got to try to block out but it
is funny yeah and Keaton like I said
he's a die-hard Steeler fan he is yeah
he was at Super Bowl 40 we had him on
the turf fellow NFL Network beforehand
that's awesome and and after the game he
was just ecstatic yes they beat the
Seattle Seahawks that night yeah and
he's just as DS as Pittsburgh through
and through it was they come yeah he
really is someone someone recently told
me that he was like walking down the
streets of Pittsburgh or something and
they smell Keaton and they were like I
got to say hi and then he ended up just
like talking their ear off about the so
he wants to do penguins what why not I
mean there is I mean there they're on
fire yeah so tell me about American
assassin and why people should go see
this movie what you like about it well I
think people should do what they want
you know you don't have it
it's true country no it's um but yeah
you know it's it's based off a series of
Vince Flynn novels 16 of them and you
know it's a very beloved book character
it's got a lot of fans and to be honest
you know I thought I wasn't aware of the
books when I was first sent the project
myself and you know my first read of it
was there was very grounded in real
action story you know entrenched in this
very emotional and strong arc of this
guy kind of you know experiencing
tragedy in his life and how that changes
him and how that kind of sets him on
this path to become an asset in a way so
right it's a cool story you know I've
always I'm a big fan of action movies
you know but for me it's always got to
got to have the story with it so you
know and I believe this one does
hopefully hopefully other people agree
and yeah go check it out yeah it's it it
it is got some great people in it you
included and Taylor Kitsch Friday night
like Friday Night Lights fans remember
his Riggins absolutely and he's the man
to and yeah everyone's really good in
the movie and Keaton's great in it too
and people have said that you know they
never seen him like this before
which is awesome too at this stage in
his career come on still be yeah so it's
cool yeah I mean you know hopefully it
hopefully it goes over okay well good
luck to you
thanks ray you got it man the Jets are
Owen one yeah your fantasy team is on
one yeah jets are on pace for Owen 16
yeah but American assassin is one a no
but thank you man I'm Tara hearts yeah
it's in theaters near you on September
15th at dylan o'brien on twitter follow
him and of course go see american
assassin Friday September 15th the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
radio stations across the country and
audience
if you like that download our app please
just if if it's a memory thing just
delete other apps you don't need those
apps this app the rich eyes and show up
you need that